technology is behind us rather than
ahead of us but it does eventually join
anyway thank you all so much and I
apologize and in some secret way I'm
thrilled that Columbia is confident in
in in the media in the moment of once
again learning from Ken this is this is
a very special occasion arguably I don't
know when the school turned a hundred
years old
in 1981 that might have been the other
one but this might be the biggest
occasion in the history of the school
since its founding in 1881 with two
students who passed a school that was
asked to think about the question of the
city in 1881 when America was 28%
urbanized having been 15 percent
overnight as 40 years before and 50%
urbanized forty years later so right in
the middle of rapid urbanization so this
school is not just a small about the
city's it's a product of cities and
since the world population world is now
50% urbanized and the population is 500
times the size it was in 1881 the
academic responsibilities of this school
have grown exponentially with time and
it seems to me to say the very least ken
is one of the few figures that can meet
that challenge the school itself I think
cannot I think that universities now I
needed to think the question of cities
and actually the current state of the
university is inadequate so the way
cities are evolving and the real
laboratories for the future lie outside
of New York and this gives New York
still now even more powerfully than ever
the reflective capacity and I think it's
in that spirit that there could not be a
greater honor than to sit and listen to
Ken the reason this event is special is
because it's a conference curated by
Kenneth there are rumors that he's
having a birthday next week there are
rumors that he's about to turn 80 these
are just urban myths urban myth says you
know we're like bulletproof look at the
gutter no way he's turning 80 no way
anyway he moves too fast to celebrate
just one more decade as a card-carrying
workaholic there's always work to be
done
Kenneth is always through sharpening his
focus and moving forward he's exactly
there their historian on the move this
is a conference to celebrate and learn
from Ken's latest thinking this is not a
celebration of the glories of the past
but actually the kind of challenge of
the future it's a chance for us to maybe
guess at what he's going to work on next
because you know him right that's why
you're here
and you know all of his tricks I'll
point some of them out to you so that
will make it more difficult for them to
him to use them on you but he's going to
use them on you and you'll have no
defense there's no vaccine against
Frampton he is how he's gonna do it
firstly he's gonna apologize in the
first second third or fourth sentence
but usually all four he's gonna tell you
he's completely disorganized and that
he's brought the wrong slides or that
he's brought slides and we're supposed
to be in PowerPoint he'll apologize to
you for being so inadequate and then
you're done in because now you're
softened you don't know whether to be
super annoyed that the guy didn't
prepare himself for you fifties
especially since you arrived on time
today and you maybe just annoyed that he
didn't bother to get himself together or
you might even feel sorry that he's been
so overwhelmed followed by you but of
course in the end what's really worse is
that you feel guilty totally guilty for
having as it were forced him to turn up
and perform our unit so leave hazard for
having you feel guilty for having as it
were lured him away from his writing
this from his friends and from his
family but at this point of course you
just stand to feel so soft and warm that
he will then slowly and steadily change
your mind if you or a give you and if
you didn't have one when you walked in
there
which is as you know quite the norm and
I could find you here
the higher you may rise actually so to
the extent that you listen to can you
will be repositioned within the
marketplace you won't rise so quick but
boy will you have something to offer
anyway he's just softly showing you some
stuff and the thinking and examples will
become more and more decisive be warned
slowly you won't even notice it or
everything suddenly becomes very clear
and there are no apologies at all and he
might be criticizing you in the middle
of then it all sounds like entirely
reasonable and then he starts making
points I mean points will be made who
else makes points today I mean can you
name any other writer who makes points
now your children will tell you well
your making points would be a pretty
reasonable thing for an academic to do I
think there's only one person who makes
points I mean actually numbers them
right who has a point would be the next
thing to say right not so many and then
at the very end just when these points
are coming in 1 2 3 4 5 6 I think
sometimes there has been 8 so I don't
know if it's climbed above 8 has it got
to 8 maybe today is 8 at that very end
and be careful of this and this is the
point which you have least resistance he
will snatch defeat from the jaws of
victory in the last 4 sentences again
the four sentences keep a warning sign
for he'll apologize again for having
failed to fully prepare again and it
will criticize himself putting to some
obvious gaps in his presentation you
don't believe it of course absolutely
don't believe these thoughts in fact the
more he discredits himself at the end
the more dignity is given to the points
and of course that's his point so you
walk away with so you walk away with the
points right which of course are the
same ones you heard last time but
layered and evolving right they've
changed and why have they change because
actually it was quite serious about
those gaps in the logic genuinely modest
about them and generally worried that
the argument is fragile so he then works
on those
I mean he's very serious about being
uncertain which is what scholars are
supposed to be it's what universities
are for to as it were house uncertainty
so that that can be transformed into
hypotheses which could be taken to the
world nothing is more boring than a
teacher that knows what they're talking
about or thinks they know what they're
talking about anyway those gaps turn
into seminars lectures essays and then
books and so the self deprecation gives
way to an at the unabashed beauty and
clarity of the thinking that special
experience of listening to can their
privilege to listen to them think it
becomes a massive communication it
becomes a media event and he's a media
phenomenon since 1972 this room has been
at the center well when it got restored
and renovated and so on has been the key
this room I would venture to suggest
although this will be uncomfortable to
Kane perhaps as a part of him I mean
part of his body and certainly part of
his brain so I made it a few notes this
morning just to try to clarify then and
now the introduction to can begins this
is I just wanted to say a little bit
what I think it means to listen to Ken
in this room and then of course that's
why you turned up in the morning know
where you'd miss this one right and it's
absurd i how do you how do you possibly
capture the special qualities of Ken's
voice if I could there wouldn't wouldn't
be that special and you and I wouldn't
be here and also it's a voice that's
continuously evolving and that's the
point of the conference today to hear
what's the next step in their evolution
perhaps I would venture to suggest of
voices only a voice if at the evolves
why else would you bother to listen
ken is just simply somebody who want to
listen to one of the very very few he's
our teacher whether in the classroom or
not or rather he turns the whole world
into a classroom right here one of the
things he does is turn the world into a
classroom for a moment this room seems
to be the real world and the rest the
outside seems to be the classroom and he
patiently and relentlessly shows us how
buildings in all corners of the planet
speak about whatever the highest
aspirations of our society could or
should be the class never ends the
thoughtfulness never ends we all happily
stay in class especially speaking for
myself and others if we disagree with
this
there or there and there and there and
there right because what else do you
want to do but listen to somebody to
which you are almost agreeing with but
not quite and then the conversation
begins because we are architects of
course and there is one thing we never
disagree about and that is that there is
something there in architecture around
which we cluster and this something is
what Ken shares with his students and
it's the thing that turns the students
into colleagues and the colleagues into
student scanners and architect he speaks
as an architect to fellow architects he
very rarely strays outside this
collegial relationship and I just want
to note that he may be the most widely
read and widely influential voice in our
field but he's probably the most
narrowly focused to that field he almost
never leaves the work and thoughts of
his fellow architects that's why he
speaks so efficient affectionately and
so tenderly about buildings the point I
think I'm probably wrong but I think
that I hope I'm not the point is that
it's never the particular building or
the particular architect that really
matters no matter how honored they may
feel by his words he expresses his
affection his tenderness towards
architecture itself actually he's not in
love with whoever he's talking about
that architecture right there is sort of
sensual and intellectual qualities and I
would say especially responsibilities
and it's also a unique to Ken that
architects always circle around actually
for for centuries
I want to insist on this tenderness this
love of architecture and its unique
resonating yet ever so fragile capacity
to express the highest cultural ambition
and hence Ken's palpable disappointment
or even sadness I think it's more
sadness than anything else when
architects don't live up to this
potential especially when buildings fail
to separate themselves from the
marketplace the routines I would say of
the marketplace and thereby failed to
help us see our world differently anyway
I would like to celebrate Ken's
tenderness or to say it another way but
actually exactly the same thing to
celebrate his intelligence because what
use would intelligence be if it didn't
help us to tender ourselves and to be
tended towards our colleagues our fellow
citizens on the whole planet and I would
say even if you think about Ken's most
recent thinking about ecology the whole
planet itself since
tenderness is so rarely celebrated in
universe
is there are no academic rewards for
tenderness even if it might be the real
goal of all thinking universities like
anglo-saxons and here Ken and I can
present ourselves as experts I'm not
good with emotions or we're very good at
not being good with emotions let me be
then a little bit more academic if you
think of the teaching of modern
architecture the most influential and
persuasive manifestation of our
discipline during the last hundred years
let's say modern architecture there are
only in my opinion three textbooks that
is to say three books whose relationship
to the field is so as it were guide and
to keep guiding there are literally
hundreds of books about modern
architecture and lots of great
candidates to be textbooks of modern
architecture but there are only three I
think that if you're simply an idiot if
you haven't read them and I don't think
there are any idiots in this room or at
least if there are the exits are clearly
marked these are books that you read and
reread every few years something like a
flu shot to act against the waves of
stupidity that keep rolling in in our
field number one space time in
architecture by Gideon 1941 number two
theories and design in the second
Machine Age Reyner Banham
Peter Reyner Banham 1960 modern
architecture critical history Kenneth
Frampton 1980 you'll notice this 20-year
rhythm the flu shots keep working by the
way Gideon still works by juice but even
the flu shot if you need to add let's
say from new strains the story takes us
from Prague where Gideon was born to
Woking where kin was born and that's
quite a jump it's definitely a movement
towards the anglo-saxon and quite
specifically you can follow these books
moving their way from Prague to London
as Germanic art history escapes the
horror as the pre horrors and the actual
horrors of the Second World War and
makes it way to New York take the first
book written by one of wolfman's best
students a product of the hygienic
tradition of art history who defected
the man who
from art history to write reviews of
architecture and art magazines then
architecture magazines and then became
the very very act of secretary of cm the
policeman of the union of architects
literally the policeman who's in and
who's out who flies and who doesn't the
man with the checking out whether you're
modern or not the one that writes the
official history of modern architecture
from within the very engine room of that
movement the second book the PhD of one
of Nikolaus Pevsner but not just papers
that was also Gideon and blunt person
that was the father figure to be
assassinated as well fathers are but
Blanton and Gideon were there and of
course the Courtauld was the very house
of Germanic art history he he then is an
apprentice further working on ancient
past who gets trained at the court hall
so he can combine a kind of really
technical working-class feel with the
kind of quasi aristocratic class of the
roots of art history he presents the
first academic account of modern
architecture modern architecture with
footnotes basically footnotes get
attached to modern architecture in 1960
it's a truly beautiful analysis and a
great read but it's not written by an
architect I think that's very important
to understand the third one is written
by an architect and that's all you need
to know it's not about archives actually
the sources are always secondary or even
tertiary and so on what's primary for
can is the voice of one architect to
another thinking thinking thinking about
what architecture is trying to be
thinking in the end about
responsibilities but sharing a lot with
Gideon actually especially in the sense
of being in the engine room the sense
that history is in the cause of the
present Benham - of course as you know
but but there's a deeper affinity I
think with Gideon and hence the need to
keep updating with new editions like
Gideon - kind of as it will keep the
vaccine working to keep the past as it
were alive and kicking penis to be
better anyway I've gone on too long but
I don't think you can go on long enough
for Ken what I'm trying to say is the
obvious kennis gift to our field was
simply to bring the voice of the
architect to the young discipline of
architectural history it's still
extremely young and the bringing that
voice to bring our hope that is
the architects Hope which is a very
fragile I think beautiful one naive
relative to the marketplace but
endlessly for that reason beautiful or
another way to think about it I think
ken has acted for a very long time as a
protector of that hope he just kind of
stayed near it while the rest of us
misbehaved and misbehave I do and Ken
this is your room that I welcome you
back to
well that's a hard act to follow
anyway thank you very much it's thank
you all for coming
I have some other thank you switch well
first of all I have a once again to
thank Mark wiggly and also been
prosecuted who was in charge of public
programs here because they came to me
and said well more or less
as it were that this house would like to
do something on the occasion of your
80th birthday so what what is it the you
should say what you would like and and I
I sensed that that is a kind of you know
I mean sort of floating somehow vaguely
is the idea there's a number of scholars
whatever would come and speak as it were
newspapers within this kind of academic
tradition which was sort of as it were
be the the the necessary permit to
actually producing a published best best
rift I think they are caught and we're
cold
probably still are caught but so but I
felt I didn't want to do that maybe also
I felt that I might be made
uncomfortable by some of these scholarly
contributions so I saw they were trying
to dodge that and and so this is a kind
of anti fest rift in as much as it's
known there's no shrift involved except
the words of well my own words and marks
works but also the works words of the of
the five firms that are collected here
to to make this presentation and I
suppose that might even make a book on
I'm sure it's worth it should be I am so
confident about all five of these
practices that I'm sure it merits a book
and particularly perhaps a book that's
under one cover if one still putting
books into covers that he is and so on
and and I mean I think the other point
that mark made before I want to other
thank-yous I want to make before I
really start but I won't make this too
long because we're already as you know
behind schedule but the the other point
that mark made perhaps not so directly
is the fact that you know basically
whatever else I might be I am architect
monkey you know that is for sure
I think and and though it's very corny I
think it does I still believe that those
that can do and those who can't teach
I think it is that's how it is you know
I was trained to be an architect but I
decided at some point I painted myself
into a corner actually when I was a kid
you know I I know that was a destiny
already there I before I could write I
feel till you know books full of fake
writing so clearly it was a pathology
from the beginning I mean I also drew
but you know the the writing you know
there's something a bit weird about that
anyway the writing was on the wall so to
speak you know even if it wasn't writing
and but it would anyway they've become a
little more little more intelligible and
so the reason all this actually mark was
telling me you know with him where and
he knows a lot more about William rather
than that than I do
it's one of the kinds of Mystique's of
this place that I am the where professor
of architecture and there has been one
more before me another invention
Romualdo juggler and I don't know what
will follow me but one thing I do
remember is that when McDonald's is no
longer a member of this faculty like to
say where is the professor you know I
mean like that and sometimes with
justice and so I still haven't quite
arrived the written substance of this
thing the other point I would like to
make is that although this is really
five presentations of five very vital
architectural practices I mean of course
these practices are implicitly if they
theoretical and and I think you know at
times also architects will make it clear
what is the discourse that lies behind
we realized work
and so I and but then I want to thank
these five because they did they
responded without hesitation and and you
know and and someone I mean they've come
from great distances so to song from
well any distance to wrong to Vancouver
San Francisco I mean it represents for
very busy practicing architects a real
effort to do that and to squander a
weekend also in do in this house anyway
they are here and I'm very grateful to
them for that and then I I do briefly
want to thank Thomas Makia who actually
made this these five put together well
the the the the textual material that
companies four five flatscreen
presentations one of course for each
practice the the presentations
themselves being put together by the
firms of course and so this is my spiel
that I actually never once did prepare
okay anyway when I was asked by Mark
Wiggly the Dean of the school to
determine the nature of a public event
to be staged on the occasion of my 80th
birthday which is sort of becoming
normally I think one celebrates the
birthday on one day and that's it
goodbye but no this is a sort of
protected affair it's rather ominous I
think but in any case I opted for
inviting five distinguished
architectural practices to present their
work in succession as the basis for a
collective reflection on the status of
American culture of architectural
culture in North America it should be
evident from the work of these five
practices and their respective partners
who graciously accepted to participate
in this somewhat unusual not to say
eccentric exercise I deliberately
construed the term North America to
include Canada as well as the United
States since my ostensible role as a
so-called curator not a strange term for
me I wish to draw attention to the
exceptional quality of contemporary
architecture in Canada which in my view
over the
year's New York opinion still marriages
most of the time to ignore so the
mixture here Canadian and American is
little tiny absurd polemic all
anthologies are in some sense invidious
and preposterous anthology such as this
comprising only five examples of five
practices is bound to be even more
invidious than most and I have here to
bake at once for the indulgence of all
those distinguished American architects
whose work will not be represented
during the course of this event by way
of making some kind of amends I can only
hope that this election might be read in
the future by some potential publisher
as a sample of a much larger anthology
which would afford a quite different
critical tape on contemporary North
American architectural production than
that to which we are exposed by the
mogees media about time this of course a
little cranky right you know I'm getting
Mark said you know I have this kind of
very ambivalent relations with media and
I am sort of inextricably mixed up with
it I said what I'm getting is in a way
is you know that I think what is
basically kind of relatively a critical
media you know a media that won't take
the responsibility of making choices
and choosing to support this and not to
support that you know and and sticking
the their necks out I mean I think most
with one exception
there is one amazing editor in this room
Luis Fernandez Galliano who I think you
know certain way it does stick his neck
out and and produces I think the best
architectural magazine of record
anywhere still apart from my editing
protect preoccupation with Canadian work
I wanted this somewhat biased anthology
despises curtailed scope to focus on
three particular points in the
trajectory of a potential creation as
this on for today within the boundaries
of the United States that's to say two
representatives one each from west and
east coast stanley saitowitz from San
Fran
go and Steven Holl from New York while
the third intermediate point no I'm just
talking about the American architect as
opposed to Canadian on the symbolic
triangle would be carried by Rick joy
from Tucson in the southwest never
ceases to remind me I'm not in Tucson I
was born in Maine but anyway he does
actually live and work in Tucson that's
and but of course builds perhaps to an
extraordinary and over many different
regions of North America and elsewhere
however schematic not to say arbitrary
nature of this section of selection is
it was not solely determined by
geographical location despite my bias
towards the north instead I would like
to think of them that for all the
prejudices of taste my selection of
these architects was determined in the
last analysis by certain characteristics
values and preoccupations that may be
found to an equal degree in all of them
at the risk of resorting to banal
criteria I would like to suggest that
despite creating fundamentally different
work all five of these late model
practices manifests the common concern
for the following five expressive
factors which may be characterized as
for me anyway landscape volume or if you
like the more hectic word space craft
material and light well we may commonly
assumed that these expressive factors
are invariably present in all works of
architecture I would like to put it to
you that today this is far from being
the case for not uncommon ly we
encounter spectacular works that
displayed little concern for the context
and the typography in which they are
situated or just as frequently we are
confronted with buildings in which
everything is given over to the tactile
aesthetics of the materials surface
rather than to any significant
articulation of the space within no
names as they say no Pedro but you can
fill in the spaces instead all of these
practices
are committed these practices these five
points in Norse ways to situating and
integration in the work in hand into a
specific context and landscape and while
they are all equally preoccupied with
material expressivity they do not pursue
this concern at the expense of not
recording sufficient attention to the
rhythmic articulation of space finally
there are the diverse somewhat
disconnected attributes of the
manifestation of craft and the iteration
of life which every one of these
practices displays to varying degrees
without in any way being reduced to
mimicry and mean mimicry of each other
by craft I mean first and foremost the
craft of architecture itself as a
practice that which Herman Hershberger
once characterized in my presence and I
love this phrase the skill of an
architect as though in the last analysis
it is still a trade one a trade one has
to master it wasn't going to imagine and
synthesize in detail the complex and
articulate work with total assurance and
conviction inseparable from this
overarching concept of tectonic craft
lies the cultivation of craft in terms
of manual technique which were ever
augmented and transformed by model
technology still prevails in my view as
a non plus ultra of course reproduction
in the field of architecture this brings
me to the most elusive attribute of all
name is the fluctuating iridescent
quality of life which a mod which is
modulated by a structure over time a
spectrum of luminosity which not only
varies from one practice to another but
also from one building to the next it is
perhaps the most important and
unpredictable phenomena and as such may
be seen as the subtle ineffable
consequence of all the other attributes
I mean spaced podium craft cetera the
remains in the work of each of these
practices other one other crucial
characteristic that I have so far failed
to mention namely and I don't know what
else to call it but I've called it here
their capacity for
logical invention whereby the building
becomes a programmatic catalyst for the
realization of conditions and metaphoric
significations not entirely foreseen
either by the client or the architect
prior to the occupation of the work what
I have in mind can perhaps be only
clarified by society and certain works
for the way in which both program and
form come together as to transcend their
separate genesis and intent as in the
large overhanging roof say of the
Gleneagles Community Center in West
Vancouver by Pat cow architects which
goes beyond its passive climatological
function to symbolize the status of the
society of the community that that kind
of thing is what I'm after well let us
say halls building for our university
housing the schools of art and art
history we're in a particular spatial
juxtaposition evokes the
interdisciplinary nature of the
institution as houses while at the same
time activating the landscape of which
it is suspended it could well be argued
that all of this is too aesthetically
determined or that it is my old
preoccupation with critical regionalism
masquerading under another guys all that
the prism dystopic ruptures confronting
the society are not being adequately
addressed by works of this genre despite
their not too infrequent public
character to this objection I would like
to argue that architecture has its
intrinsic limits and that while I do not
subscribe to its hypothetical autonomy
since it is the one cultural form that
is any X trick ibly mixed with the life
world and dependent on material material
circumstances I would nonetheless insist
that at the same time it cannot be
expected to answer for the dysfunctional
self-destructive convolutions
perpetuated by global corporate
capitalism in its decline I'm reminded
having said that of this wonderful ever
ism of our aziza
which is I tell them that she marked
also
- I challenge university authorities
that architects are specialists in non
specialization but they cannot take that
not even as a joke I believe that today
promises to be a rather rich and intense
event in which the presentation of the
five practices with the break for lunch
short break the law will follow in the
rather dense succession to culminate at
the end of the day in a relatively brief
but hopefully fruitful panel discussion
between the protagonist and the audience
of myself I suppose before entering into
the festivities of a reception the order
of the presentations will be standing in
sight of its size of its that that DOMA
architects San Francisco Shin Sutcliffe
architects Toronto Rick joy optics
tucson patio architects from Vancouver
and Steven Paul from New York our own
Steven Hall of course who teaches here
we have decided to accept two or three
questions from the audience from after
each presentation in order to maintain a
certain vivacity the seizure will be to
gather these three questions hopefully
work out and and then ask the speaker
just to cover all three at once
basically I've only I just want to add a
kind of writer which is that which came
out of experienced which came out of
seeing these five screens this morning
because I you know III obviously was
aware of a certain familial connection
between these five practices but I had
not expected the the juxtaposition of
these five screens with the with the
continuous rotation of images in each
screen to be to present such an
incredible rich body of work I had not
expected
I mean sometimes you you if that if the
names weren't there you would be sort of
slightly uncertain at times who had done
what you know as well but but I have to
admit that but I think it is incredible
it is very encouraging I think it's it's
amazing rich body of work I hope you
enjoy
so I have the other to prevent stand
aside kids
I want to begin with thanks firstly for
being here for this milestone in the
life of a person I so greatly admire and
secondly to Ken for the many years of
being a Raider
helping steer architecture so many times
since I left school and began working
the values and measures you have
provided have directed my efforts and
helped me continue on an architectural
agenda and weather the tangents and fads
that have emerged your voice and the
work you've upheld has been a continuous
conscience and source of aspiration and
inspiration it's hard to imagine what
architecture or my own work would be
today without the concepts you have
crystallized over the years the first
piece I remember was the article in
perspective 12 which presented maze
under there's a birthing in times rather
than an object and totally changed how I
thought about architecture soon after
Allison and Peter Smithson visited our
school in Johannesburg and showed their
English modernism and mentioned the idea
of a felt parallel that set me on a path
that are later transplanted in San
Francisco but was only able to name
after the writings on critical
regionalism appeared this continues to
be the direction of my work both schools
I attended stopped teaching history
before the last chapter banister
Fletcher and it wasn't until modern
architecture a critical history that
there was a comprehensive account of the
work that interested me most that book
was on every reading list that I ever
made at UC Berkeley studies in tectonic
culture was the final nail in the coffin
of post-modernism each of these to name
only the most obvious are pivotal to my
work so to thank you for the sister
vastly understate the huge gift you have
given I'm going to speak about practice
the word practice is derived from the
Greek pragma meaning action the theory
which drives our practice is pragmatism
from the same root pragmatism originated
in the United States in the 1870s and
was always represented and has always
represented at a sinky American Way of
thinking pragmatist argued that the
function of philosophy should be to find
out what definite difference it makes to
our lives beliefs are rules for action
and to develop a thoughts meaning we
need to determine what it produces
pragmatism does not have rigid canons or
obstructive dogmas at and stiffens
theories and is genial and entertains
any hypothesis that has practical
consequences for each project we
developed a set of principles derived
from the particular situation and
specific site to drive the process and
I'm going to show three this is your
verb ina laughs the first thing I ever
knew about San Francisco was from songs
long before I moved there working in a
city of Suns and being part of building
the city has been my focus I've
constantly searched to understand its
nature something I think M Rose best
captured when he wrote this city is a
claim upon a map of fog there are
hundred and seventy nine thousand
building parcels in San Francisco a
hundred and seventy three thousand or
eighty-seven point eight percent are
residential housing is by far the most
important constituent element of the
fabric of the city so naturally this has
been central to our work
the first Victorian info was our office
love both in 1991 followed by a number
of other buildings in which we developed
prototypes and an approach to urban
housing 15 years later we both the
building next door and later this one a
couple of
blocks away then we had the opportunity
to build a whole streetscape with you
ever vinyl of
I've always been interested in
continuity in buildings that are more
than themselves the subdivision Andry
division of land the grids within grids
to the scale of individual units and
eventually furniture is the ordering
device of the city at yerba buena laughs
this urban logic is extruded vertically
to become the structure of the building
each Loft is sort of as a stacked lot
the building is a rigorous and
repetitive subdivision of plots our
urban housing emerges from highly
modulated and systematic plans we use
the lessons of mass production and
although they are claims that current
technology technologies will bypass the
need for repetition we have used the
economies of serialization to increase
quality we've never had an interest in
arbitrary variety preferring to make all
units the same and good and when
inhabited the neutral spaces we provide
result in much more difference than I
could ever imagine
I've always wondered how architecture
could be a tool of liberation very early
I began to confront the question of
indeterminacy versus programing smooth
versus striated space the first building
are both outside Johannesburg in 1976
was an artist loved it was conceived as
a scaffold a frame in which to make a
painting it followed two presidents
Maison de verre and the Eames house I
thought of it as an instrument rather
than an object more like a telephone
than a conversation more like a camera
than a photograph I was so intent on
destroying program that I refused to
have a bathroom a toilet floated behind
a corner on one level attempt attempt
set on another a shower on the other the
dining room was a mobile cart which
rolled around the house and out into the
garden through the hangar doors in our
current housing in order to provide
indeterminate deprogram space kitchens
and baths
our accumulated collapsed and minimizes
these servant programs are compressed
into thickened walls eliminating the
whole idea of rooms and replacing them
with minimally differentiated continuous
fields the plans consist of thickened
walls and spares the service walls
double our structure and align
vertically stacking planning all
electrical and sprinkler ants chased
through these zones producing added
economies all lighting emanates from
these dense walls this process of
reduction compression and repetition
provides opportunities for expansion and
the reallocation of resources to
increase qualities in other areas
through hierarchical unities elements
are assembled grouped and minimized
providing the maximum amount of free
space for the occupants to determine
their own program in the case daily
houses of the 50s a new model dwelling
emerged in California spacious open and
free that redefined the domestic
landscape as a fluid continuous field
this house fully embraced the mechanisms
and appliances of modern life placing
them within the same with the same eases
furniture this is the dwelling model
we've used for the design of our
multifamily housing density and
intensity have their own demands and the
projects we do are the result this is
the main
and the front of the other finalists on
the lowest level is lip workspace which
is a kind of regulated artists activity
and then basically the stacked units
above with the recesses which are code
requirements which actually establish to
prevent large buildings from being built
in San Francisco there's also this sort
of sense here of the building as a
continuous extrusion of the sort of
structure and fabric of the city the
building and bridges between two zones
of the city this is a 40 foot high zone
and the building steps down to meet the
styling here you see the texture of the
fabric of this part of the city which is
replicated in the building this is the
ground floor plan showing the artists
activity commercial lofts at the ground
level the main lobby entry and the empty
to the parking which is very within the
center of the building and then another
set of lofts with garden units which
connect onto the Le way and a second
smaller lobby entry and a more typical
floor you see the parking now contained
within the doughnut of units and the
sort of ability to actually drive in and
park at your kitchen which is kind of
what I realized was very marketable and
part of the American dream that you
could drive into your kitchen and here
you see the sort of setup of the
building with the parking at the center
the larger scale and this street war
which is comprised of bays and balconies
which articulate the edge as it meets
the city and then the podium which
connects to the 40 foot height of the
zone behind with the same sort of
treatment
Edge's and sort of tower part of the
building where it steps back and other
unit types are established this is the
kind of typical articulation of that
edge with these carved balconies whether
aid the outer edge is channel glass on
the street and then chair glass which
carves a sort of private code into the
face a view on the boulevard side on
Folsom Street with the larger scale and
then the V stepping down to the garden
units which connect to the Le way and
the smaller scale of the city and this
cascading of scale down to the Le and
the garden units and another view of
that street wall and this is a slide
that's always interested me because this
building was actually built after this
building so it's a sort of counter
contextualism with a horizontal channel
glass is here replicated as clapboard
siding and the sort of rhythm of
structure becomes a series of bays so
it's it sort of shows that contextualism
works both ways this is the
organizational structure of these
vertical Lots with a 16 by 16 space in
which the bay and the balcony and a
house are created and the variation of
this in a fairly random way to produce a
sort of urban texture and richness and
the view of these lanterns of channel
glass and the balconies at night and
again this sort of street structure of
the variety that's created within this
very simple system and the images that
start to emerge which are reminiscent of
some of the moments of the victorian
city of towers and
and the building on the boulevard at
night the key to this building being
able to be delivered in the marketplace
at a competitive price was actually in
the system that was used to construct it
which is highly repetitive these ones
which are basically the same form that's
used all the way up these sliding forms
which are inserted and pulled out and
then the fact that um the production of
the building is also the completion of
the building so after the concrete is
cured the glass is inserted and at that
point the building is finished and
waterproofed
in comparable buildings that are being
built in San Francisco using similar
techniques of construction seven trades
follow each other to create the seal
because the concrete's basically hidden
between some kind of skin of framing and
window inserts and flashing and dried
metal or some kind of final rain screen
so he had two trades actually achieved
the completion and the building is
actually built from within itself so
that it doesn't need any scaffolding
because they sell a little actual work
that needs to be done on the exterior
and these savings actually were
translated into using better materials
so typically in the competitive
buildings it's impossible to get this
much glazing whereas here the entire
surface of the building is actually
constructed of glass and this is just
the process where you see that as the
building is being still poured the
finishing of the lower units is possible
and works going on so the time frame
gets compressed which is a huge economy
and yeah with by the time the roof is
being put on the building's already all
sealed up and being completed on the
interior the lobby which is basically
all the structural in this building was
all structural concrete so that it's
pretty raw
but we did do some tuning up for example
the saw cutting in the structural slab
and staying to produce a kind of finish
for the lobby and the interior ii lobby
the interior streets which are 320 foot
long so they were thought of as a kind
of 8 by 8 cube which is articulated in
each doorstep with this color that sort
of announces the front doors and the
unit types of which they actually fall
with four subtypes that are created by
the requirement to set back parts of the
facade in the units as they were
delivered which is basically a raw shell
and in this case as urban housing it's
the sort of cubic dimension rather than
the square footage that is a measure of
the kind of generosity of the building
and then there was a kind of option
center where you could purchase your
finishers and this resulted in an
enormous combination of units a 200
units in the building I've been in many
of them they almost all unrecognizable
from that either even though the bones
are so similar through this sort of very
simple technique of just allowing people
to choose their their final finishes
this would be a typical kitchen the
bathroom laughs and then again the sort
of finish and another unit with a
totally different feel because of the
finishes chosen there and here the sort
of condition of the outer edge of the
building with this translucent
horizontal glazing which creates a sense
of privacy and then this carved in clear
glass section which creates outdoor
space every unit has its own private
outdoor space and some of the units on
the podium setback have these large
garden terraces and again a view of the
on the boulevard and as part of the
streetscape of the city these are some
of the offshoots of that building here a
multi-use building with offices
townhouses flats and a whole variety of
different types of units here building
on a very steep site where you enter at
this upper level which becomes a public
space and then got up and down into the
unit's here in a very traditional sort
of neighborhood on Russian Hill a
reinterpretation of bay windows into
screen porch outdoor spaces here in the
South of Market area and near shelves
where there's a conflict of use between
residents and nightclub and a kind of
screen building which can shut itself
down at night to keep out the noise at
the intersection of Market and Octavia
the gateway to the city this is where
the freeway basically ends in the city
and so this is the Octavia gateway
building which is the entry to this new
Boulevard and the whole northern part of
the city at market and page another
mixed-use building at Fulton right
behind the city hall here building which
takes the traditional crenelated bay
windows streetscape and turns it into a
curtain wall so yeah there's only one
trade actually which will be involved in
the completion of the building in the
mission in this very vibrant sort of
cultural area of the city again
mixed-use in Oakland a tower in
Cleveland for case university these
buildings are under construction now
student housing for California College
of the Arts and a project in one of the
art of districts of San Francisco Park
Merced which is more suburban and in
this case where each house has given a
garden as part of the urban
kind of like the next project is the
Tampa Museum of Art Museum's began in
ancient times as temples dedicated to
the muses where the privilege went to be
amused to witness beauty and to learn
after the Renaissance museums went
public with palatial structures where
the idea of the gallery arose a space to
the display paintings and sculpture
later museums became centers of
education researching collecting and
actively provoking thought and the
exchange of ideas by presenting the
highest achievements of culture museums
became a stabilizing and regenerative
force crusading for quality and
excellence the role of the modern museum
is both aesthetic and didactic both
temple and forum the design of
contemporary museums can be
characterized by two polar approaches on
the one hand buildings which entity
works of art in themselves independent
sculptural objects on the opposite end
of the spectrum are museums as
containers as beautiful jewel boxes
treasure chests whose sole purpose is to
be filled with art this museum is a
neutral frame for the display of art an
empty canvas to be filled with paintings
it is a blank container a scaffold
infrastructure to be completed by its
contents a glass pedestal supports the
dual box above the building floats in
the park embracing it with its
overhanging shelter and reflective walls
it is a hovering abstraction gliding
above the ground the site and brought
with some complicated conditions it's in
a floodplain with an 18-foot high water
level so no art program could be
catered within that floodplain and it's
part of a reconstruction of the downtown
of Tampa and the famous Kiley Gardens
which have fallen into pretty bad
disrepair over here and the hairy wolf
building which I'll show you over here
but tamp is a very suburban sort of city
so this was an attempt ready to create a
cultural center with the new park a
Children's Museum and then the Tampa
Museum of Art the program on the ground
which is basically all non art related
programs except for delivery and
handling begins on the Riverside with a
bookstore and cafe a very large kind of
multi-purpose space which is the lobby
some meeting rooms and then other kind
of support program the building is
actually very clearly zoned in two
buildings the one the building that has
all the public programs of art and
display and the other all the programs
of support which are extremely large
compared to the actual usable gallery
gallery area each of these two each of
these buildings are organized around a
code the court of the galleries which is
a kind of pivot that you have a very
itinerary to experience all the gallery
spaces and then the support building
around another courtyard in the rear and
the rest of the support building offices
here you see the sections and the way
that the two separate buildings are
joined by this gap and the two
courtyards which arranged the programs
of the two buildings and then this
massive cantilever which produces shade
and creates a kind of public porch the
first time I went to the site it was so
hot that I actually had to go back to my
hotel and wait for the Sun to go down
so I decided immediately that the one
thing that I was going to do
shade out of the building and then the
program actually really facilitated to
that decision and here you see the
structure that supports this massive
40-foot cantilever which are a series of
share cause onto which these girders are
attached and then the cantilever is
hanging from one of the essential
nature's of museums is collection and
collection creates the needful expansion
everybody always runs out of storage and
so many contemporary museums are fixed
objects the dinah la edition saket was
really important to establish a system
which would produce the possibility of
growth and so there's a kind of math
building with a grid of cause which
established a sort of tartan and then a
kind of set of building blocks and an
easy ability for the museum to sort of
perpetuate itself and grow one of the
big problems of the project was that the
museum currently has a very minimal
collection it's more like a kunst also a
lot of the shows are actually borrowed
and very very strict insurance allows no
daylight to be available for them in the
galleries so basically and we had this
sort of blank object and mariel
architectural context to work out of so
the two elements that are charged to
think about in terms of how to enrich
the quality of the exterior of this
container was the sky and then also the
water and to make a sort of object
without content or image that would have
the sort of shimmering changing life
like nature and the way that we achieved
this is through these perforated metal
panels which happen to be produced by
McNichols which is a company that
operates out of Tampa the the other
thing about this museum was that it had
an incredibly modest budget so we had to
really be begging for many in it was
finally built for under $400 a square
foot which is much less than some of our
custom houses so basically the way that
we created this effect was through this
series of perforated panels which were
detached six inches and slipped to sort
of introduce this and start over more a
pattern and as you move around the
building and walk towards it it's
constantly flickering and reconfiguring
so here you see it on the Box on the
pedestal and anyway the the kind of idea
of this huge public porch which absorbs
the parkin and reflects the park through
these glass walls and the approach from
the town along this pathway underneath
the porch towards the river which is
where the lobby actually occurs so that
you walk down this really sort of pipe
sort of space and end up right near the
water before you in turn
this is a sculpture quote which is part
of the gallery space up above and one of
the courtyards around the working part
of the museum and the idea of the museum
always has a frame and he had a split
between the two parts of the museum
and the skins here a single layer but on
the right-hand side the two layers with
the brackets which detach the outer
layer a view of that split from the
inside and the lobby of the building
this is the main incheon the lobby is
entirely glass and on the two ends which
parallel the river it's completely open
so that the space runs through and links
other cultural institutions like the
Performing Arts Center and the
University of Tampa that are they in
this is a view through that glass lobby
the stair which goes up to the arc
program and the court that arranges the
gallery spaces
the sculpture Court which overlooks the
river and the galleries which were
intended to be as neutral as possible
almost like sort of snowstorms it's
white punished concrete and Barisal
fabric ceiling so that to eliminate the
problem of not having any day life we
try to create a kind of day sky with
artificial light and all of the
mechanisms are held as high above the
ceiling as possible to try to keep the
spaces neutral as possible and the slits
are replicated in these so cuts in the
polished concrete this is the sort of
inhabited space of the gallery
and various transformations of this
neutral canvas
to have the equivalent of the more a
patterns present themselves at night we
arranged a series of LED lights in the
gap between the two skins and this
presents the sort of image of the
building now as the possibility of the
museum almost turning itself inside out
at night and becoming a big urban canvas
and artists have been hired to create
various kinds of artworks on the surface
the life of the porch at night
so the museum as in urban porch a jewel
box floating on a glass pedestal
hovering in the park
a - between brown and sky the museum is
frail this is Beth Shalom which is the
last project that I wanna show it begins
with the problem of Hebraic architecture
which doesn't really have an
architectural tradition when these
amazing buildings were being built in
Egypt Abraham is the founder of the
Jewish nation was and had visited Egypt
was living in a tent so the Jewish
tradition sustained itself and survived
not through architecture but through the
word and through ceremony rather than
through objects there's now a kind of
synagogue tradition that when can really
base a building on but one of the
amazing sort of statements that our
rabbi Herschel made was that the the
equivalent of the great cathedrals for
for the Jesus's are the seventh the
Sabbath's which marks every week through
time this this nation and so it's it's
time rather than place that that the
Jewish religion has perpetuated itself
through but in digging there are some
examples of architecture the first being
the tabernacle which is described very
fully in in Exodus and was spelled out
by Moses and the interesting discussion
about the tabernacle is that everything
is in great detail but it's always about
how things are connected much more than
the things themselves so that the idea
is that the cabinet
Hell itself is not important in itself
it's only important in the way that it
connects the community around it and
it's it's that that is its role the
tabernacle was formalized when and the
Jews settled in Jerusalem and the temple
is the sort of built version of the
tabernacle and this again is always
described in terms of ceremony and in
terms of the relationship of space to
use so these diminishing chords are
explained as they're where they use was
there where they died my dimension was
greatest there was their greatest use
even the act of building was more
important as a ceremony and the way the
building itself was built it's described
that the building was built in silence
for neither Haman or X nor any tool of
iron was allowed in the construction of
the temple and here another example of
the idea of a building as an instrument
this is a stair to the altar and when
the priests climbed the stair irregular
rises and treads they sang a song the
song of a saint and through their voices
and in the rhythm of the song they were
cemented to the building and the last
piece of this is this which is kind of
the center of the Jewish world today
which is a wall of this temple with no
real aesthetic quality not very good
stonework but still the most holy and an
end sort of sacred center that Jews have
another piece of this history is that
after the temple was destroyed the
synagogue emerged as the place of Prayer
and this is Masada and on Masada and
there is this remnant of the earlier
synagogue that's known and you can see
that it's very much as space in the
round the ceremony was conducted in the
center and a very kind of communal
and focus type of space douche
the surgical spaces got affected later
by and the church models and became
frantic and performance-based but the
original way that the worship has always
been carried out is very centrally and
communally and here you can see the
diagram of that space the first
synagogue that I worked on is in La
Jolla where we used the traditional
European model of synagogue so it still
has this Terrace kind of look in the
center but it embraces one aspect of
synagogue life which is now no longer
relevant which is the separation of men
and women it's not used in that form in
this particular synagogue or in any
synagogue many synagogues anymore but
basically the original idea was that
women didn't participate in the service
and said in these balconies up above and
all of the activity occurred with men on
the lower level in the synagogue that I
worked on in San Francisco the synagogue
itself was the first conservative
synagogue to dispense entirely with the
separation of men and women and it was
very important that the building
reflected this transformation which has
worked and gave rise to this form this
is the site which is along Park Presidio
and Clemente and an early plan
established and two religious buildings
to be built there was a synagogue here
which was demolished for the new project
and initially the synagogue's were at
the the religious buildings were not
send it to normal darling and they were
allowed additional height and so on but
the Carol's railing doesn't recognize
that right and said the synagogue had to
conform with all of the residential
zoning that any exceptions are for
steeples which Jews don't have
so it basically had to conform in in the
residential envelope and this is the
Christian Science church which was met
earlier which is much larger structure
here you see the site plan and initially
the building which had occupied the site
had built out the entire lot what I
tried to do was use the existing really
odd pattern and put it into this
courtyard so that it was continuous with
the neighborhood which I thought was a
nice gesture but the neighbors hated and
tried to slap controls on how we use
that space and so on the whole process
of going to a sacred space in the midst
of a city was of interest to me and I
wanted it to be a kind of transformative
journey where you entered into a
courtyard went up some stairs and then
arrived at that other courtyard and then
when in such a sequence of
transformations on the lower level are
all those sort of daily and support
activities the offices a meditation room
a library classrooms and a connection to
an existing school building which wasn't
part of this project and then this is a
building where there's a daily Chapel
where morning and evening services are
held every day more meeting rooms and a
kitchen which is really two kitchens
this is the continuation of that journey
up into this Court which links the three
key elements of the program the century
the school and a social hall and another
view of that here you can see the
section of the building where you see
the sort of elimination of the idea of
balcony in this continuation continual
kind of folded space where everyone has
a view of the center which is where the
Torah is read and
and lifted and the structure that
supports this sort of wine glass object
and then the more simple skill Fred
social hall building the view from the
street and the kind of country bar which
tries to evoke memories of this wall the
entry into the first courtyard the first
layer of sort of transformation then
going up the stairs to the main
courtyard where the religious spaces are
housed and the space in the rear yards
which connects all of the activities of
the synagogue
this was the first thinking about the
project and obviously in these drawings
the memory of being in this space was
very strong and the idea of this space
of community bigger than the traditional
synagogues but operating the same with
this sort of focus on a center and idea
of a community in prayer rather than a
sort of performance of a service and the
actual space and one of the problems of
the Hebraic tradition is that
iconography is equated to idolatry so
it's very hard to have any decorative
elements the crenellations was actually
about an acoustic issue with the hard
surfaces but the other element of
ornament is the shadow menorah which the
structure casts in which changes the
space as the sunlight changes through
the day so you see the sort of menorah
that animates the space time one of the
things about the description of the
tabernacle that I mentioned was the
emphasis on connection and the idea of
connection as being the sort of element
of community and yeah what I tried to do
was make all the connections out of
light so everything's pulled apart and
joined by light and it's like that sort
of holds everything together this is the
view of the century at night
the chapel which took some of the
stained glass from the building that we
demolished and intensified it and uses
it as a kind of memory of the history of
the congregation view across the court
to the administrative building the
Meditation Center which is a junior
garden which connects to the offices the
social hall which suppose out onto this
court in this multi-purpose room and
again leaving the synagogue and going
back to the city
I just wanted to end with my seven pints
about architecture and I'm sure they
pretty much knocked off from Ken and I
apologize if they've been misinterpreted
but the first has to do with idea of
lenses each building begins with the
sight and the particular desires to
transform it buildings are earth made of
matter and a continuation of the
geological processes that produce their
sites part of natural evolution a
building marks and amplifies its unique
spot on the globe like a lens it brings
to focus and magnifiers its particular
time and space and place the second is
to do with flee invisible the essential
medium of architecture is space air
rather than substance matter which
contains the emptiness architecture is a
construction of charged words friends of
opportunity fields of possibility I'm
interested in space more than meaning in
the architecture of movement and flex of
time and event rather than object and
monument I'm interested in the emptiness
that material constructs
I'm interested in the invisible the
generative ideas of modern architecture
emerge from both from the consideration
of buildings as systems related to
machines or natural organisms or the
phenomenon of the city I'm interested in
similarity and dissimilarity in
relations of relations in theme and
variation or the order and accommodation
I search for the highest common
denominator to establish the field of
operation as a framework of unity and a
panorama of resistance I'm interested in
the art of math that deals with the
logic of quantity shape and arrangement
in the study of patterns providing
unifying generalizations for fields and
subfields in the science of structure
which enables focus on the encompassing
comprehensive the inclusive and
universal I'm interested in buildings as
apparatus rather than object as
instrument rather than monument I think
of architecture support for human events
more like a camera than a photograph
more like a telephone than a
conversation I'm interested in
generosity and opportunity rather than
program and spaces I've always resisted
the idea of programming as authoritarian
and aim instead for the generic and the
general the purpose is to provide a
caring and opportunity for the unique
and specific to be determined
indeterminately through the process of
occupation in the search for the
authentic over the image the actual
materials and systems of assembly the
processes of construction become they
aesthetic I want to make objects that
expose their cause buildings that are
perceptual process I like to think of
construction as growth not an idealized
form but the actual Performing of the
work made precious I think less about
architectures art and visual than
architecture is cooking and haptic I
make buildings by the gathering and
assembly of ingredients the plan is the
recipe time traditionally architectures
tools encouraged the description of the
static or very slow we were unable to
talk to ourselves about how buildings
live in the rhythm river of time we
could not hold on to light and shadow or
describe a building's life inhabited and
used both projects teach the lessons of
time of their changing presence from day
to night how they empty and fill and our
frameworks for gatherings and
celebrations how they settle into their
worlds the reality of times passage and
the processes of occupancy and use our
design material and the last is green
amongst the host of new idols the green
architecture movement has produced we
remain more interested in intelligent
design working with nature
using solar orientation shading day
lighting window Larry as well as
industry energy harvesting technologies
for Sun wind geothermal and River
cooling we use wholesome materials and
renewable resources and build likely
using the least possible material and
effort to come in campus the most
possible volume and space simplicity and
synthesis are our goals simplicity is
the property of being clear and concise
the principle of economy and succinct
nur's census synthesis is the property
of complex elements being organized into
Jara hierarchies and groupings reducing
elements without reducing functionality
an entire practice revolves around ideas
of economy and optimization
if there are a few questions you should
solve
I know it's locked that's a lot and
probably take a while I mean you can of
course save the questions till the end
where we will have a question and answer
session but if there are some questions
we could take now
can you speak up please
but I guess I guess like what my
question is like you have a very sort of
rigorous process where you go about your
design and I'm kind of wondering with
your material considerations the way you
sort of dress use materials so using the
channels last year with wayna the way
that you sort of use the formwork of the
concrete in in the temple the Jewish
temple is there any sort of specific
like intentions you have there
like for instance I saw and in the
kantha Museum you follow the lines of
the ceiling on before there's there any
attention like that in like the
proportions of the channel glass for
example the channel glass if you look at
San Francisco it's it's the city that's
built out of horizontal clapboard and
it's a very like pervasive sort of image
that you have of the city when you see
it it's always you know there's a lot of
elements to the city it's a very ionic
kind of City it's quite you know
feminine and and delicate but there's
that sort of pattern that I wanted to
deal with but in a way that was specific
to their project in the museum the idea
of tracking those lands was to create to
sort of make less out of things you know
to to make the neutrality more poignant
so the the fact that they just become
markers measures you know dimensions of
the space and try to minimize the
difference I showed you quite clearly
like I love concrete I have an obsession
with it and you know it's it's a
terrible material to love because it
it's got its own world and life in it so
the material that's very hard to control
but
I still risk it and let it live through
my buildings and I'm always happy to be
surprised by it but sometimes you know
it doesn't do what I want or what I
wanted and then I have to rethink it but
in the synagogue I mean I put Calais in
it which is not something that I would
normally want to do because I don't
really like the idea of like ornamenting
surfaces you know but I wanted it to
evoke thirsty I had a lot of resistance
from my clients about concrete because I
think it's a lien cold and and it's hard
working with Jews I'm a Jew so I can
serve it but you know so anyway I could
kind of persuade them to use the
concrete was to tell them that it was
going to look like Jerusalem stone and
they believed me but you know the reason
why I do love materials like concrete
and the kind of materials I'm always
looking to use are materials that don't
have a surface that are the same all the
way through so that through time their
quality actually gets amplified and
improved they can sort of show the
quality of time and use and they don't
fall apart and sort of des laminate and
that's one of the things about the
material
thanks for a very interesting and if I
could have beginning uh I I wanted to
ask kind of like falling from the way
you've represented the first project
about the how you respond to disowning
the particular restriction on height you
know in the synagogue project because it
seems to me that I can only imagine I
you know this may be a projection that
that the change in the in the zoning
that you indicated where monumental
religious buildings were not allowed to
express themselves differently than
secular housing but what you said is the
you know predominant type in in Cisco is
seems to be the product of a say a
cultural set of cultural values you know
in other words one can imagine a group
of left-wing planners sitting in a
office somewhere in San Francisco
thinking we really need to secularize
the city and so the question is why not
or whether you think it's possible for
architecture to to encourage or evoke
secular experience in the context of
building a religious building rather
than evoke religious feeling in in
contrast to the secular neighborhood
especially in the tradition of Judaism
because many synagogues are very
understated you know basically converted
houses my own opinion of the quality of
cities is that they need these cultural
markers to actually create variety and
identity I mean the way I navigate the
Richmond District which is sort of row
after row of 25 foot wide little quasi
Victorian bungalow is by the landmarks
of unique buildings that exist on
corners and I was more interested in
doing something like that then just
making eye
San Francisco is an incredibly boring
city if you get away from the center you
know you could drive for miles and it
just looks the same it's so I actually
am more interested in finding the right
way to introduce some kind of iconic
moment thank you for the presentation
my name is Frank gardener from Detroit
graduate from in 82 I'm struck by the
indebtedness to LaRue CIA's work in
particular in the first townhouse you
showed in its relationship maybe to the
maison plan a and to the the loft
housing and its relationship to the
immobile villas and the unitary
habitation and I'm wondering if you
could I'm sure we're gonna see a little
bit of that from everybody but be
interesting to hear your thoughts on but
if you look on the first page of the
complaint there's a letter from the
Koontz Martines
in volume 1 and he writes to Martine who
was the sort of teacher of my teachers
and says how surprised he wasn't such a
vibrant modern movement being you know
so alive in South Africa so early on so
my roots are totally from that work the
reason why I studied architecture was I
lived in the greenside and Marty
in green with that I lived in was like
oh you know I was it was it was like
thank you
so I think we have to move on because of
obvious pressures so it is a very great
honor to introduce British gem of the
practice British in Howard sotloff
Toronto and extremely distinguished
architect and teacher teaches in the
University of Toronto for many years
those Howard Sutcliffe and Bridget soon
are graduates from the best-kept secret
I think of one of the best-kept secrets
which is the School of Architecture in
the University of Waterloo which is much
much cheaper than any American school
and also probably better than in the
American school because it also has a
systematic negotiable system of teaching
students for a few years and then they
have to go work in an office when they
come back again and Florence it also was
split between being educated as it were
academically and learning on the job is
much less in the as I understand it in
the school in Waterloo than anywhere
else and I think this accounts for the
extraordinary prowess of this firm with
that I'll leave it to you
thank you can can everyone hear at the
back good okay first of all for my
partner Howard Sutcliffe and I it's
really an honor to be here to celebrate
in this special event just in case you
haven't known Kenneth Frampton is
passionate about architecture and he's
been sharing his enthusiasm optimism and
infectious love of the discipline for a
long time so I think it's really only
fitting that in honor of his birthday
we're here to share ideas projects and
experiments and it's really an ongoing
extension of what he has been doing and
will continue to do so thank you very
much for including us I guess one of the
things about our practice is that we
have built a very small body of work
we've been a practice for about 16 years
with the studio right now we're kind of
close to the largest we've ever been so
about 10 architects including Howard and
I and our project straddle the line
between public and private commissions
most are built in Canada and most are
built within about a three-hour drive of
Toronto which is where we live in live
and work so for us knowing a place
through its geomorphology its climate
its cultural history allows us to more
accurately calibrate the provocation of
intensity between the wild and
unpredictable forces of nature and the
control processes of contemporary
fabrication and somehow our work lies or
the situated between these two
conditions in a way this image is our
most recent project and I guess I think
of everything we do as a bit of an
experiment and we're very fortunate to
have a range of clients who kind of go
along with it and allow us to kind of
experiment at both small and large
scales so in a way for us the kind of
exploration of ideas through the medium
of architecture is a kind of
preoccupation this was a very early
house we did in a back alley in Toronto
kind of light-filled interior court that
is exploring the sense of really being
an exterior court and so for us this
question of light which is germane to
this kind of conversation throughout the
day is again a kind of preoccupation at
the same time we live in this enormous
country the second-largest country in
the world with a very tiny population
and so whether you live in the landscape
or you live in a city the kind of the
image of landscape the notion of
landscape the mythology of landscape is
all around you this is a recent project
in a Toronto ravine a kind of covered
outdoor space that slips and frames
views of the landscape but kind of
interest in the kind of way that this
indigenous forest of black locust
walnuts and native species are kind of
framed through the kind of frame of
modernity and then also I'm water which
is kind of not one of the things that
was kind of brought up in the kind of
number of points of the introduction but
has always been a fascination for us and
one of the things that that hard and I
love about water is that it makes in
effect
Stanley said the kind of invisible
visible so these questions of steam and
mist and ice are kind of made palpable
through the kind of register of water a
winter is a really long season and so we
think about it all the time and we think
about not just this verdant summer green
which is easier to do in other climatic
zones but we actually think about how
our buildings will be imagined in a
snowstorm or kind of in this kind of
winter condition and we think about our
buildings from the outside in and then
even though it's not quite the kind of
fashionable thing in most architecture
schools today we think about them from
the inside out and so we're kind of
preoccupied with this kind of push and
pull between inside and out and it's
sort of what it's what one of our kind
of ongoing interests as you know we live
in Canada and in a way the majority of
our own work is actually located at what
I would describe is the bottom edge of
the Canadian Shield so if this is the
shield
the shield is described as a kind of
stone necklace around Hudson's Bay so if
you see Hudson's Bay here this kind of
ancient metamorphic rock the oldest rock
in the world and the kind of way that
our work is kind of clustered at the
bottom end of what is a very enormous
geographic area and the image on the
right is a kind of view of the group of
seven a kind of group of Canadian
artists so the first people to start to
depict the Canadian landscape not as
pristine and and lovely and pastoral but
somehow to show the kind of rawness of
nature and in this view you can see the
kind of roughness of the water beyond
the kind of ominous clouds and in effect
the trees being shaped literally by the
west wind and the kind of idea that as
opposed to pretending it's a different
and more pastoral condition there's a
kind of acceptance of that rawness and a
kind of inclusion into the work itself
so we're always experimenting and in a
way what I want to do is show three
projects but in each case show a kind of
preceding experiment that informed the
thinking and the ideas of the the other
project so there's a kind of symbiotic
relationship between them and the first
is moorlands Kant but this is a project
we did a while ago it's it's in an area
called Halliburton about two hours north
of Toronto it's on the Shield you can
see the kind of building it's a camp
building for a dining hall for a camp
for inner-city kids a nonprofit group
very low budget very seasonal so part of
the idea was to use off-the-shelf items
we used a greenhouse glazing that was
very inexpensive we use natural cedars
so they never have to paint anything and
then we created an effect a space for
three meals a day
kids counselors for this dining hall and
here is the view from the dock where
you're seeing the kind of separation of
wall and roof again this kind of
articulation of all of these elements of
architecture and the main space which is
where these kids have three
a day so there's a kind of main skylight
that is the ridge going right down the
center a series of glulam frames and a
kind of hybrid condition of steel and
wood together and we love these kind of
hybrid explorations we drive our
structural engineers crazy because they
all have different rates of expansion
and contraction but in a way for us
there's a kind of expression of the kind
of architecture using extremely simple
means to do so down the center a whole
series of two by fours and they in
effect provide a kind of sense of a
light monitor so the light is actually
above they provide some shading and then
also a kind of measure of the time of
the day so in the project we watched the
the the people writing the camp close up
this building and fastened pieces of
plywood into the window frames at the
end of every season and so we actually
devised a series of briefs all A's that
actually provide the opportunity for
parts of the building to shade the main
dining hall at the hottest parts of the
day spaces that were at the scale of
children and then they can close their
whole building up in a very short period
of time the kind of idea that the kind
of extension of the building becomes a
kind of outdoor porch which is very much
part of the vernacular condition but
it's rethought and reconsidered and then
again kind of frames the landscape
beyond and then this kind of question of
the way that the building actually takes
on these very local conditions so what
you're looking at is this kind of
ready-made greenhouse glazing a kind of
siding of metal siding that's typically
used on barns a kind of cedar that is a
kind of very local condition and yet
assembles them together in a slightly
different way in a way for us at the
same time shortly after we started to
design a cabin Georgian Bay and so many
of the lessons that we learn from this
project were able to kind of absorb or
kind of synthesize in a different way
this is
painting by a Canadian artist named
Paterson Ewan he's often referred to as
the router guy because he would often
take pieces of plywood and these are
actually removed from the plywood and
then filled with an alkyl and dye and we
actually designed a studio for Paterson
before he died and he worked in it for
several years and was a kind of
inspiration in terms of the way that his
work actually tried to describe
phenomena weather climate and have you
understand the kind of power of these
different conditions so the project that
was the kind of beneficiary of the
experiment of the the moorlands camp
dining hall is this very small cabin and
we thought of it as a kind of wooden
tent so it early sketches but kind of
rendering where we're the kind of main
space really is intended to feel like a
porch so here you are in this kind of
wild landscape but wanting it to be open
and accepting of it and maybe not so
afraid of it a very simple system
thinking very carefully about
foundations a kind of adapted screw jack
from scaffolding to provide a kind of
light way of literally touching down
into this ancient rock I'm a kind of
very regular eyes system and a series of
kind of models that are kind of the
development of both the building idea
the kind of conceptual thinking as well
as the construction idea because in many
of our projects they're inter woven and
intertwined together this project is on
an island so everything had to be
thought of as a kid apart so we kind of
almost built it and then almost imagine
how you would disassemble it how you
would actually think about how its
fabricated and thinking about again the
lightness of every piece so every
element had to be carried by two people
over a rocky terrain transferred several
times and so the kind of the its
intrinsic ability to be maneuvered
through different water land conditions
was actually part of the criteria and
then we actually built full-size
mock-ups and which is some of the one of
the things that we loved doing we
actually got our structural engineers to
actually sign off on the mock
as opposed to the structural drawing so
that we could again kind of push this
question of lightness even further and
then this looks like Tom Sawyer and
Huckleberry Finn but this is how they
got all the sips structurally insulated
panels from the marina onto a barge onto
the island then have to be carried to
the actual site itself and then here
you're seeing the actual building where
you're reading the porch and the sense
of how it's actually both connected but
also hovering above this ancient rock
which is the Canadian Shield the kind of
framing of views of Georgian Bay so
allow the kind of group of seven
landscape this kind of Big Sky ancient
rock kind of west wind trees being
really part of the psyche of the place
and then the interior where the kind of
earlier skylight developed in the
moorlands camp with a very low budget
with a kind of larger public use is
refined it's elaborated it's kind of
rethought and actually used a gained in
a quite a different way so here we
actually have a curving wood ceiling and
only possible only possible in this
landscape because it was all built in a
shop through the winter
so under controlled environments but
designed in such a way to be
disassembled and then be reassembled
because this question of craft isn't
always so easy everywhere you go so in
this area to expect something like this
from local craftsmen is kind of a
problematic condition and so we have to
rethink in effect the local condition in
relation to our desire for a kind of
level of refinement and worked with
local craftsmen as well as these brought
in pieces and did a hybrid combined
condition and then framing views of the
landscape these slot narrow views of the
forest I mean at the same time these
kind of the porch light condition of
looking out to the kind of big water and
the kind of larger big sky landscape and
then a series of very light fiberglass
panels that allow you to push and pull
depending on the orientation of the wind
the angle of the Sun being able to
modify and amplify the space itself and
then the next experiment is a kind of
one where we worked on a project now
1994 a little red house it's the little
red house that could we designed in
Toronto again in a back alley for an
architect who was our client clad in red
plywood and about 10 years later the
same client came back to us and asked us
if we would design a studio and we have
Qi now have about four projects that are
these kind of pairs where we did
something a while ago and then we do
something again and it's a kind of odd
phenomena to actually have a
conversation with yourself so the idea
of so you're seeing a glimpse of the
early red house and then the newest
piece that we did on the same property
for the same client and so this is a
client who is an architect archivist and
so here is a kind of one room and we
actually applied for a building permit
for a garage and but he doesn't drive
and so hence you get the studio so part
of it was a whole experiment in light
one of the things he wanted was he has a
large what he calls a working reference
library a large collection of
architectural posters and wanted both
glowing light but no direct light which
is a kind of common condition for
galleries where you're viewing things
and so because this was a garage we
could build it on the property line a
very low budget and a series of little
light coffers with a very thin skylight
and the thickness of the wall actually
changes on every elevation so this is
the South elevation and the thinnest
wall and programmatically the wall is
for viewing this is a slightly thicker
wall and behind all of those amazing
architectural posters are a series of
bookshelves for his working reference
library and then the slightly deeper
wall has both deeper storage where all
of those kind of invitations are located
a storage of either images or books and
then garden store
on the backside of the wall from the
outside and then a sense of the kind of
experience of this kind of light filled
room but with no direct light itself and
in a way for us that was a really
interesting ability in a very low-budget
small project to really be able to
explore a kind of idea of light that we
had for another project that we were
working on so again this reciprocity
between one thing at a small scale
actually informing something at a larger
scale and it was wonderful in the
beginning to hear I'm Stan Lee talk
about a synagogue because we were
actually fortunate to be able to also
design a synagogue and I think went
through many of the kind of early
research where there's no building type
there's no requirements there's very few
things that you really have to do to
design a synagogue and it was for a
reformed congregation in Portland Maine
and I think that one of the questions
they had was about light itself and we
were able to observe a kind of sunrise
and an early morning ceremony and this
question of light was a kind of
preoccupation for us so here's a very
early sketch thinking about the light as
it would come in during sunset and then
a kind of early study model actually
exploring again this very question of
light and the kind of idea about how
someone who arrives for a Friday evening
service but also shows up for the
Saturday morning service in the same
space actually understands the
transformative aspect of the space and
maybe it's only because of the light
again a kind of prospective study and
this kind of interest again of splitting
apart things and using the light as a
kind of register and a kind of way that
landscape and water are kind of
preoccupations again framing and drawing
you from the everyday busy world into
the kind of world of a sacred space and
this kind of idea of journey I think is
very much part of our kind of interest a
kind of early site model but it gives
you a sense of the kind of project
overall so you're looking at it exists
1920s Portland public school the main
road a kind of entry courtyard between
the existing school and the new
sanctuary social hall the hallway that
really brings you into a view of the
garden a glimpse and then the main
sanctuary and part of the kind of
dilemma of the program as well as its
opportunity is to have a sanctuary for
about 250 people for most of the year
but also a space for gathering of 700
people for high holidays and I think
that's a common problem with an issue
related to religious programs library
rabbis offices and men along this linear
pathway and a kind of use of both a
skylight as well as a clear story and
here you're seeing the kind of project
from a distance we're really close to
the kind of Dunkin Donuts which is
really part of the context and the kind
of idea that the roof and the kind of
landscaping in effect frames views of
the sky and really obscures the kind of
foreground to change your relationship
to it and then here's a kind of view of
the entry court so the existing Portland
public school is it's sort of to your
right the main entry doors are here and
you're looking at the social hall which
is part of this extended space and this
is actually the first time we've ever
shown this project it was finished about
a year ago but we're waiting for the
landscape to kind of develop and so
these photographs were shot really
recently and the first time I've seen
them big so here you are looking at the
exterior cladding and so you're actually
seeing horizontal Cypress that's being
used and the idea is that it'll weather
gray so they don't actually have to
paint or maintain it and then you're
looking at the skylight but above it the
clerestory windows and then you're
actually seeing there is a skylight on
top of that so you're getting light in
these baffles from from both the side
but also above and they become the way
that depending on the time of the day
that you're there you register the light
in front or behind of the back
and again here you're reading this kind
of condition and I mean it was
interesting to sort of hear and see the
images of San Francisco because Portland
Maine is very much it has a very brick
core the working port but men should the
residential fabric is clabber as as the
kind of New England area is and so this
question of embracing the light
understanding the light both a kind of
exterior condition and then also an
interior condition so here's that
hallway leading you from the entry
toward the sanctuary itself and then
when you enter again this question of
light and the way that the combination
of the clerestory versus and the
skylight together and these kind of
tilted baffles actually provide a kind
of register understanding of the light
and they're actually times that the
congregation is there especially during
high holidays for a whole day or a day
and a half and so this kind of reading
of the space through the light is
actually part of the kind of experience
itself so when it is a high holiday the
sanctuary in the social hall which are
often seen as two separate spaces are
able to become linked and read as
totally one space and one of the things
the congregation asked us to do was to
create a space that was both contained
and open-ended and so here you actually
have the containment of these two walls
west and east the west section is
articulated differently than the East
section to really capture the light at
this latitude and then one side looks
into the courtyard the entry court which
is very urban and the other side looks
into the sanctuary garden and here
you're looking at the Bema the reading
table the NER Tamid
and the the arc holding the Torah and a
kind of view at night where you sort of
get a sense of again this transformed
condition and the role of artificial
light really kind of providing a
different reading of the building in
relation to natural light so this kind
of
sort of thinking through a both day and
night and then a view in the evening
where that kind of hallway the walk from
the hallway through is kind of also made
legible the kind of section of the
Westside being actually different than
the section of the Eastside because of
the latitude and then the sanctuaries
relationship to the reflecting pool and
the garden that surrounds us so again
we're using subtle section to really
actually create a space that they
actually now call the sanctuary garden
and so it's really a kind of idea that
the garden and the sanctuary are not two
separate spaces but are really
considered one space and they gain this
kind of viewing of the light and this
changing quality and so the kind of idea
that almost becomes a calendar to
understand the Sun through the day and
then again you know neither Howard and I
are Jewish but we were invited to a
design the kind of key elements for the
Liturgy and so here's the the kind of
Ark and the Torres but also the NER
Tamid so it is the kind of everlasting
light which has got a solar connecting
to a solar panel on the roof and a
series of kind of layers of bronze mesh
to kind of interpret that kind of
symbolic aspect and then the kind of
last shared experiment is a kind of
early house that we designed in the
Thousand Islands which is in Lake in the
st. Lawrence River between upstate New
York and southern Ontario and this is in
a place called Howe Island which was a
fairly predominantly dairy farming
island and we loved this kind of
agricultural landscape but it was
actually being transformed by being
bought up and turned into fairly
suburban laws and so the first thing we
did after we designed the project was
seated the entire five acre property
with the clover meadow I mean it smells
amazing in the springtime and it kind of
creates a kind of agricultural condition
in this sort of slightly changing
suburban landscape and the really
important part of the project
this kind of section which steps down
and so when you enter the project you're
actually viewing it from an upper level
which is obscured and we use fiberglass
and then you come down to actually be in
a reflecting pool that's almost as big
as the actual house itself so here
you're actually seeing this kind of
obscuring of the landscape and this was
a kind of this isn't a system we just
used two layers of this fiberglass with
an airspace in between it was a kind of
summer project and so we experimented
with this kind of way of obscuring the
landscape to then allow you to come down
and to be in the landscape and then even
though you're on an island you would
think you would get to build really
close to the water but all the
regulations prevent you from doing so so
you end up being having setbacks and so
the reflecting pool actually creates the
idea of island and makes it a reality in
the project and so here you are in the
kind of main living space where the kind
of big sliders open up and you're in
this kind of very three-dimensional
modern screened-in porch and again this
question of water and its proximity to
buildings and these other conditions
that it creates where your interlocking
light landscape but water becomes a kind
of predominant player with Bennett
allowing you to read maybe these more
ephemeral or slightly invisible things
and the always cognizant of it and the
kind of idea of a water landscape being
as powerful as the kind of ground
landscape and again what happens here is
that then a local farmer comes and cuts
down the clover meadow and then two
weeks later it rises up again so again
even though it's not an agricultural
property the kind of idea of the
agricultural cycle actually gets
embedded into the architecture of the
project the idea of it kind of reading
as a lantern in the meadow so this idea
of this glowing condition and you don't
see it all and the section and falls
before you so in a few years ago we were
asked to design a project for a
mathematician who is also a concert
sounds like a kind of first-year studio
that you might said in some architecture
school architect magician violinist he
likes curves sloping side he wants a
performance space for 150 people and he
also likes glass so it kind of was a bit
implausible and as you can tell from
some of the glimpses of our earlier
projects we really weren't people that
did a lot of curves so it wasn't like a
kind of thing where we said oh that was
an easy thing and took us quite a while
to digest and then synthesize and kind
of really kind of redefine that for
ourselves so what I wanted to do is show
you sort of process and so early study
models and we work a lot in physical
3-dimensional models thinking about the
site where it kind of reads as one scale
from one end and then as a different
scale at the other side large study
models that we built working with
acquisitions developing specific aspects
of the project and then the idea of
section which is again something that
hasn't really been discussed in the kind
of numerous points that have been made
but is actually a game part of what all
of us do and is a kind of maybe for us
the section is more important than the
plan or the plans look fairly simple and
straightforward but then how they're
realized in section for us becomes part
of the kind of the pleasure of working
through the architecture so here you see
a project where the kind of two-story
section from here and then down the hill
and it keeps going and even though the
drawing stops the property and the
ravine continue beyond and again the
section where you come in at an upper
level and descend down to in effect what
is the main performance space or 150 of
your closest friends and then descending
down again almost into the ravine so the
idea that the journey through the
project should actually feel is that
you've entered a ravine whether or not
you go outside is a kind of totally
separate issue and then I have a series
of plans that go from the lowest level
up so you're kind of reading an effect
or kind of pool
relationship directly to grade kind of
there's a study and gallery areas that
skirt the edges and rooms that are more
pushed into the side of the hill and
then as you go up this is the main
performance space with kind of this
undulating edge really almost being a
contour line pushed out to the edge of
the building and then again back of
house spaces and then the kind of main
entry level where you enter and then
descend down with these upper-level
spaces almost reading as balconies
during a performance and this drawing is
an early study but again if you think
about the island house and the idea that
you don't actually see the entire
landscape at the beginning but then as
you descend down it reveals itself and
then continues to reveal itself as you
move through the project and so I think
that was really the kind of idea from a
very small project that we actually took
in it elaborated and so here you're
seeing the 97 fins that we used at the
kind of upper level and in a way this is
only possible because of computer
fabrication and moving back and forth
between a kind of idea and very simple
hand models to kind of being able to
realize them in a kind of fabrication
format and to be able to do it in a way
that's actually affordable and in doable
so this kind of use and interest in kind
of it exploiting the technology in a
really positive way and here are sort of
some of the kind of different fins and
they all were fitted but each one
music going between the fabricator shop
and the site and moving back and forth
and then here everyone bidding on the
fin package had to produce a fin so in a
way it actually allowed us to do quality
control while we were looking at tenders
at the same time and it was amazing the
different approaches for the same thing
you would have thought it would be
really similar but they were actually
more different than you would think and
then at the lower level below that
there's a more standardized spin so
you're actually seeing in effect the
kind of assembly of these elements the
structure and one of the things that
happens in much of North American
construction
there's these layers of construction so
it's like wearing different coats for
different kind of sporting events and
thinner layers and thicker layers and we
wanted you to be it's had to you know
clearly operate within that realm but
for you to be unaware of that so what
happens is that you actually don't read
a window frame the frame actually gets
slotted into this element the fin is
actually protruding into the room and
there's an EP cap on the exterior that
actually provides the actual cladding on
the outside of the building so here
you're seeing a kind of full-size
mock-up or you're seeing the kind of
shaped fin that is the more standardized
spin the IPE cap and the way that the
glass slips in so that all that assembly
is there but just not expressed and then
a kind of series of templates that are
really part of a game this time that we
are in as architects or the ability to
use the computer to do all kinds of
things that would be quite expensive or
difficult in another time
so this is actually a kind of metal
template that was all laser-cut and
actually used to create this kind of
curving condition on the site itself so
this kind of and we're sort of
fascinated and interested in these
interim pieces that are not the final
thing but they're kind of essential to
realizing the final thing in the way
that you imagine it and then the site
itself so the project itself is on this
hillside you can see the CN tower and
this is a ravine called a Don Valley
ravine a project called the brickworks
which created much of the bricks the
physical fabric for Toronto and a kind
of series of winding paths through them
so this kind of very special ravine
landscape within the city and a view of
it from the ravine in winter where
you're actually seeing in effect these
shaped contours of the landscape and
their kind of relationship to the kind
of shaped interpretation that we had of
both curves and contours of end light
and landscape the entrance to the house
where there's a kind of two-story
condition and on the more urban side
we're using a shaped H glass
so there's a kind of outer skin a kind
of airspace and then a double glazed
sealed unit and then LED lights in
between that create a kind of night
condition as well and then the point of
entry into the project and then the kind
of sense of panorama Tirana is a very
Victorian City a lot of zoning
requirements that prevent you from
opening up on your side yards and really
wanting a kind of feeling of being more
panoramic and being in the landscape and
this sort of sense of arrival and entry
and the kind of use of both clear
stories and a kind of way of lightening
and creating a kind of journey or
experience through the project in a kind
of way that you have glimpsed spaces and
here you're actually seeing in effect
precisely the experiment of the Island
House the density of the upper level and
then the openness of the lower level so
it's almost like a wooden curtain that
opens up as you enter the ravine and
then heading down into it where you're
getting different views along the
contour line and then the kind of
architecture of the kind of railings and
ballast rods where they actually become
a kind of other curving experience as a
counterpoint to the space itself and the
kind of way that the kind of edges at
the second floor the upper level
actually become balconies during the
performance times and the kind of
overall view of both the upper level of
the main floor and then the kind of
landscape of the ravine tumbling down
the density of the upper fins in
relation to the openness of the lower
fins and then a kind of winter view
where you're really understanding the
transformation of winter light a very
different condition and really important
for us to think about and the sort of
descent down the ravine so outward
stairs almost as if you're traversing a
hillside and I kind of
of the way that different materials come
together the kind of glazing tucking in
the IPE caps here the wooden fins on the
inside and the kind of need to deal with
weather sealing and all of these issues
of our climatic zone but maybe not to
necessarily have to express them and
then descending further down and the
lowest level being a kind of pool that
really extends itself out into the
landscape and really reflecting in this
case this kind of winter experience of
this sloping hillside at the same time
our client asked us to work with a glass
artist Mimi Gelman and we worked to
create a blue glass there so here's a
kind of a private stair not part of the
public sequence and so you're in this
these there blue glass shingles that are
laminated they go from dark blue to
light blue with a skylight over the
whole thing and it's quite narrow
because it really again is not a public
sort of part of the program but very
much a way just to get to an upper level
and then what happens is its impact is
felt in other parts of the space you see
glue PSA's of it and you understand it
in different ways from different parts
of the house and here you're seeing the
back side of it where you're reading the
curved glass there are a series of
bronze glass Clips and stainless steel
cables that allow it to float and
levitate and then music stands that were
part of the kind of design and then a
series of images just of different
performances contemporary dance a kind
of this is the Simone Bulevar Orchestra
portion of that Orchestra a kind of
chamber music group and this is a group
called the Alden bird connection which
uses voice and piano and so in a way the
idea of this kind of oscillation between
public and private is for us kind of an
interest in the kind of way that the
space has a very domestic program but
also a very kind of other public
presence at the same time so I just
wanted to end in
with a series of photos that we took of
the seasons and this kind of idea of
landscape for us as something that we
experience every day so I just started
with the same view from spring through
to summer through to fall and then
finally winter and just in closing I
guess for both Howard and I architecture
fuses together both poetic ideas inert
materials physical sight and social
conditions and architecture trades on
its ability to touch and shape people's
lives in profound and meaningful ways
and its complexity but maybe apparent
simplicity is kind of what it's all
about
and so thank you so much for letting us
share a series of experiments engaging
light in landscape
so we'll try it briefly the same if
there are some questions yes speaking in
terms of maintenance who is responsible
for fixing one of those louvers if that
breaks so there was a question about
maintenance and fixing the louvers are
all fixed so they don't none of the move
so you move in relation to them but they
are actually fixed both upper level ones
and the lower level ones I got a quick
question - I think Cedric price wrote
phenomenal transparency and so he's
talking about the layering of different
sort of densities colors different
feelings understandings of the space
through this layering materials the most
important point in the building is that
membrane where the outside meets the
inside and so I'm seeing this very rich
sort of layering of like this
transparencies but then I'm wondering
how it does that transition happen like
sensient glass with snow behind it yeah
so in a way I think the sections that I
showed the cutaways both the large-scale
working drawing details and then the
full-size mock-up were precisely trying
to show that where all those assemblies
are there we live in a climate where you
have to build from minus 40 centigrade
to plus 40 centigrade that's the zone
that we have to kind of look after and
so it's not a it's not a kind of joke
it's like you as an architect it's a
kind of requirement that you address
that so what happens is that they're all
double glazed sealed units and you're
and they're actually capped in the kind
of in that detail you don't see or read
the frame of those windows but they're
actually embedded within the kind of
assembly and so that's part of the kind
of experiment for us of how to really
address our climatic zone
while actually having this kind of these
varying and different experiences at the
same time so it's both a challenge but
also an opportunity at the same time so
the question was about budget everyone
always has a budget and budget is always
an issue I think that one of the things
that our client understood that was that
curves were not as simple as straight
lines or straight volumes and so he was
really an amazing client that actually
really understood that and really it was
I would say curves were actually part of
the program brief they were not
negotiable he's uh he's a calculus
professor and so for him this kind of
fluid volume and curves were actually
for him the spaces that he wanted to
enjoy and so we worked really closely to
kind of realize that good ok so I think
we're going to break now it's 1:15 you
should come back here at 2:15 I just
want to get your attention for a minute
I know some of you may not be on our
mailing list and we're planning to
package up some of the the material
that's been presented here and send it
out if you would like to receive
material please just hand me a card or
something or I can give you my email to
send me information see you back this
afternoon